3 points
Oh, hello, I'm worried about whether I'll be able to do it again
tomorrow. Seven princesses of language study
.  If you study, you have to be the
one who is the student.
I
think there are, but it's
fine in the vacancies that successful people are the only students who seem to have taken independent leadership first,
but that's more important than that  Outside of the classroom, the
key is how far you can take the lead and study. So
,
my seven
secrets right now?
No, it's outside the classroom.
Take the initiative and study on your own. Take enough time and
study in a fun way. Read a fun and interesting book.
The
third thing is that you can rank ninth on your own, so even if your teacher can't tell you, you can
really pay attention to various things.  is very important.And after
all, we want to increase that 4th agreement.It's
not a woman who needs market conditions, but by listening a lot outside at Park 34,
it will increase
.  Hey,
don't get frustrated and keep studying independently,
bit by bit.
Let's do it, let's do it with a dictionary, but if you have it, you can succeed
.
What should I do if I didn't understand it when I read
it?
I didn't understand or forgot what I studied  Even in the midst of instability like
that,
it continues to be that way.
But it doesn't have to be there.
I'll study on my own, so it's the last time.
By all means,
please come and visit us there, and of
course, talk about various things
with me, or exchange various opinions with the members of our garden linq.
thought